[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going bros
it's me
[Music]
welcome hey this [ __ ] sucks all right
a couple weeks ago i did a dna test
that's right and i finally got the
results
in my email so i thought that's a
moderately
fun video to do yeah let's share my dna
with the world
that's a good idea why am i losing my
voice
is this working in my favor am i like
saikuna right now
um anyway uh neanderthal what the [ __ ]
is this
why do i have a neanderthal report hey
felix
you have more neanderthal dna than 10 of
other customers
what a weird way to phrase it you mean i
have less neanderthal dna
than 90 of customers why am i losing my
voice
help me yeah that's good that means i'm
not a bugaboo
brain that's you i'm pointing at you
guys
let's go this face rig is so [ __ ]
[ __ ]
someone make me a good one please well
what i want to see is my ancestry here
we go here we go
here we go oh
what 100 scandinavian
what is that what does that mean can i
celebrate this or not will i get
cancelled
i can't tell [ __ ] can i reply
this is a dangerous game i'm playing
here
i mean yeah hell yeah i'm scandinavian
my dad did one of these and he got
like eight percent fin finish or
something so i guess that means i have
four percent
finished dna which you know sucks
obviously
scandinavian hundred percent
in the last 200 years your ancestors may
have lived in the following locations
yeah that's where i grew up what the
[ __ ] how is it so accurate
no no no
oh god this is why i'm losing my voice
because i'm screaming like an idiot
no norway i have no way in me
oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait didn't
didn't the vikings actually come from
norway
so that means i actually have viking the
yeah
let's go this is what i'm talking about
okay i'm not from iceland uh fair enough
that's a shame i like iceland i would be
okay with that at least i'm not finland
like my dad
cringe all right cool i had a hinting
suspicion that this was the case but
now it's confirmed uh get to know my
relatives they are
200 more likely to feel jittery after
drinking caffeine
well good thing i drink g fuel
98 of your relatives have british and
irish ancestry
yeah because we came and with the with
the sextants didn't we
what is it what does all this mean what
do i click on what do you and northern
european men have in common
be a huge penis perhaps does anyone give
a [ __ ] about this what is this
all right let's check my health how am i
doing i have a chance of
celiac disease which is an autoimmune
condition
the consumption of gluten can result in
damage to the small
intestine oh cool
wellness alcohol flush reaction unlikely
to fresh
that's true i don't flush caffeine
consumption
likely to consume more cheese mate
have some g fuel deep sleep less likely
to be a deep sleeper
this is so untrue i'm a very heavy
sleeper
genetic weight predisposed to weight
less than
average see this is really interesting a
lot of people
i i didn't realize this is part of your
dna your disposed weight
i mean obviously a lot of this is true
and a lot of it isn't but i didn't
realize just how much that is a factor
lactose intolerance likely tolerant
let's go
i told you i'm the most tolerant
youtuber muscle composition
common in elite power athlete
ah [ __ ] this sucks what does this mean
it means i know i'm a sprinter body it's
so lame dude
studies have found that almost all elite
power athlete yeah sprinters yeah
[ __ ] sprinter i don't want to be a
sprinter i want muscles
[ __ ] is this this sucks dude
dna sucks
okay let's check my traits oh god bald
spot oh god
seventy percent chance do not have a
bald spot
let's go look at my face do you see any
bald spots
no no you do not yeah back hair
oh
[Music]
72 chance you have little or no back
hair
oh hell yeah i like those odds
i like those odds
cheek dimples 50 50. i don't have cheap
dimples
cute genetic lottery dandruff 73
you had dandruff this is fake fake new
no no no what the is a cleft oh
butchen 77 percent you do not have a
cleft chin
well i have a cleft chin and i love my
cleft chin we call it butt cheek
i won the lottery on that one baby [ __ ]
yeah
look at my cleft oh wait you can't see
it i mean you can't see it
ear wax 90 chance to have wet
uh what whoa whoa early hair loss okay
oh god
74 chance you will not experience hair
loss
and thinning before yeah thank you
genetic lottery that's what i'm [ __ ]
talking about
i'm gonna keep my hair biggest [ __ ] yeah
chance of blue eyes well i won that one
didn't i freckles
yeah i do get some freckles actually but
only when the sun comes out
yeah 78 chance you experience hair photo
bleaching oh my god
so i would always be made fun of in
school because everyone's like oh you
blood you bleach your hair
i'm like no it just gets really bright
in the sun and no one ever believes me
but now i have concrete proof this face
rig sucks
just let's skip this let's just do it
like this yeah for some people frequent
sun exposure can line your hair color
yeah it's a thing i don't dye my hair
i mean i did one okay whatever hair
texture
i had a chance of slightly wavy hair and
i
lost it god damn it i had little or no
hair at birth well i don't care about
that
red hair
yeah yeah let's go
let's go i like those odds
skin pigmentation uh let's just skip
that and then skip that one now it's not
that's not important i
i see all colors unibrow what the hell
57 cents do not have a
no no no
no no no yeah i don't have a widow's
peak
i wouldn't mind one i think it looks
good when you bust cut your hair
here you can have a longer big toe eew
taste and smell i prefer salty oh my god
that's in my dna
that's so well i mean yeah that makes
sense i guess ice cream flavor
preference 50 chance of preferring
vanilla or
chocolate well i prefer chocolate this
this you're saying nothing here
cilantro i have a higher odds of
disliking cilantro what is cilantro
oh my god i can hate coriander it's in
my dna
holy [ __ ] bitter taste life we can't
taste
yeah weird and wonderful ability to
match musical pitch
less likely fear of heights that's in
dna
less likely to be afraid of heights yeah
i'm not really scared of heights
this is pretty humbling because usually
when people scare their heights
as someone who isn't it's kind of hard
to understand
like why would you be that but if it's
if it's in people's dna
you know that kind of changes your uh
perception of it
hair thickness less likely to have thick
hair no i have extremely thick hair
so a lot of this this is [ __ ]
especially this one
holy [ __ ] mosquito bite frequency likely
bitten as often as others
i i don't get bitten at all it never
happens
ever so this is all [ __ ] i get
extremely motion sick
and i wake up at five zero eight zero
nine
what the hell are they just comparing
other people with similar dna who filled
in a form or something
what does this mean i mean you're 100
right but
cute so what's my carrier status
okay i'm not carrying any diseases feels
good
good to know 100 scandinavian
well it's been real guys it's been real
to do this channel
i just realized i'm not allowed to exist
anymore
it's good to know that my great-grandma
didn't sleep around you know
not that there would be anything wrong
with that of course it's just good to
know
what the so weird i don't know why i'm
sharing this
but yeah that was fun let me put back my
avatar and maybe it works
oh god no don't look at me here i am uh
thank you for watching this video if you
enjoyed subscribe for more
uh coco melon diss track coming very
soon so make sure to subscribe
and i'll see you guys in the next video
bye bye